but in the playoffs last year particular against
the outs and in game seven he was outstanding off
we go from climate pledge Arena Gerard chipped
it to the wall and now NuSkin shovels it out to
Center Ice bouncing Puck past o and on a step
it's Alexia for baners his pass got broken up
and then B it out of the air by Jared mccan
the 40 goal scorer Morgan plays it around the
railing York Strand finds it in the corner the
game seven hero works it back to the line seam
pass schwar denied in front by gorgia wow was
Schwarz wide open the Colorado defense Sam Gerard
and Bo byon were playing together Gerard turned
this Puck over just inside the blue line and as
they scramble back to position there's barard he's
the left defenseman he's way out on the right side
Byrum's all tied up with wber and hello that's
Jaden Schwarz all alone look at the patience of
gorev he doesn't overreact as McKinnon scrambles
back but a great chance for Jaden schwarts maybe
the best of the game and gorgia beats him from 10t
prde of Colorado College who did score Saturday
against the Blues in that shootout loss for the
Kraken tried to wiggle around at the Blue Line
turns it over and now McKinnon on the hop with
Ranon it surveys NE thr for McKinnon tried to
stop it home on GR power first is a turnover and
a rush chance and if you're going to turn it over
you probably don't want to turn it over right
here as that's Ranon and McKinnon are going to
get the puck in the neutral zone a little give
and going mck last season bouncing off the end
board paddled out by grower ran Duman turns it
over and a big time save by grow guau reads pass
and shovels it to the side off to the head by
ol pursued by kagano we got the support from
his Linate Logan o Conor fighting with Everly up
ice it's K peeling toward the slot got blocked
on the way in bounces off the end boards Yamoto
toward the net tried to poke it home and Kier hit
it off the iron and now the Ken score with
Yamamoto on the reload and Seattle strikes
first Seattle starting to attack off the rush
the early Chance is going to come to the front
of the net and KY is going to hit the cross now
it's chaos nobody can sort this out and from a
sharp angle gorv loses his position watch him
get flat in the net off the rebound of kier's
shot giorgia's going to get flat in the net not
Square to the shooter and Kyler Yamamoto gets
his first as a Seattle with Ranon and McKinnon
it didn't work in the first period we'll see
how long Jared Bednar hangs with that or if he
makes a move here in Period too and remember
also a buck 48 left on the Kraken power play
to start this second well sometimes the lines
look great on the Whiteboard and then they get
out into the game and it just doesn't work and
that's pretty much what happened to the ABS
tonight so nin back down playing with leenan
and Johansson on the second unit nushin toward the
net tumbles there they score re ties the game at
one jumps on that loose Puck really nice work
in the corner by the ABS as NuSkin works the
puck into the corner and he's going to need
Puck support and it's from linin the two of
them get to work here and with a delayed penalty
linan takes the free Puck guau is out of position
there's no chance Schwarz shielding on Tage
is's able to fight that free to Mar coming
up on 40 seconds to go the Avalanche clear
ok's got it shorthanded scores and the ABS Le
marar is going to get this Puck as caves breaks
up the play Mar clears it around and dun will not
see OK Conor until it's too late OK Conor takes
it to the forehand and is able to beat guau with
the short-handed goal they're very fortunate to be
ahead here they've been the second best team they
do have the lead as Tatar walks in got it from
leinen lean drags shoots and a save by grower
waiting for a whistle he gets it well this power
play is really disrupted any momentum that Seattle
had bosi turns the puck over in the middle of
the ice it's one thing if your power play doesn't
score it's quite another when it pulls the air out
of the building and that's what this Seattle power
play is done in this third power banked out to
neutral ice here's linan down the right wing pulls
up to the slot it's Gerard and a save made by
grower to keep this a one goal game Kraken looking
to inject some energy here in the last couple of
minutes another big Collision back in the Seattle
end here's Larson draging joining the rush tried
to go short side and the blocker stop by gorv
to the Colorado Avalanche dressing room after
blocking a shot earlier Adam Larson sweet drag
move bounces down and finds burkovski he holds
it left Point sweeps it to the slot Duman moves
it across and the save made onani Gord bit to tie
the game shulz from the line big block by leinen
who tumbles is slow to get up and the Avalanche
Move It Up by Swift Joe Hanson with a shot that
miss the net and it's the corner Colton get but
gorv makes the stop and then Duman is going to
find Yanni gour much like the chance of Jaden
Schwarz in the first period so the Avalanche
have the lead two and0 to start this season with
wins over the Kings and then the Sharks meanwhile
the Kraken winless at 02 and one their first three
games in trailing as we start the Third Lung wide
of the net picked up by Adam lson the Wonder is
some sort of regression in coming but a boatload
of chances now a takeway Johansson speeding ahead
has drewan with him filtered across Drew denied
there by grow who got a piece with the blocker
6 and a half to go Avalanche by one McKinnon
pivots on to it back out kagano move for Gerard
fire him a one- timer flutters and breaks the
stick on the way in and come back out toward the
half wall Pagano on a pinch here's Gerard for R
he scores and just like that it's a two goal
Colorado [Applause] lead Yanni gourd's going
to break his stick you see it in two pieces there
he's coming back into the play you see him out at
The Point Sons Jared mccan who sits in the Box
verovski stand on at right Point met by NuSkin
verovski lost it thein got it toward the net
he scores the empty Netter to put it on ice for
the [Applause] Avalanche pretty frustrated as this
Puck bobles on him thein shoves him off the Pucket
stays with it intercepts it a second time and puts
it in the middle of the empty net on Thursday and
a game we told you you can watch right here
on ESPN against the Black Ops York Strand
pulls up he gets muscled off the puck carried
ahead here's Mason and a save made by Philip
grubauer Gord Fe back in with York Str got
blocked gor shot B off again by gorv he had
a great night sitting on one trailing by three
in the home opener here in the New Year Deep
by Belmar toward gorv another save this time on
korv as Seattle came out and played really well
and aggressively early on it finishes with a
terrific stop as K is all by himself you see
him take it that extra half beat poked out by
Gerard into the circle for burkovski and that
will do it here in Seattle Colorado has started
this season 3 and0 they get a 4-1 win over the KCK